Vous vous souvenez dans ma vidéo sur les maladies du futur, on avait parlé des nano-robots
qui vont combattre les maladies au cœur de votre organisme
et bah des machines incroyables... y'en a d'autres.
Des technologies incroyables, la médecine en utilise déjà, et depuis longtemps
Je vous propose un petit tour d'horizon
des machines médicales, les plus improbables
On commence avec une machine du passé :
le poumon d'acier
Alors un poumon d'acier, c'est pas une prothèse métallique
qu'on greffait aux insuffisants respiratoires ...
En réalité c'est un caisson pour aider les malades
atteints de paralysie des muscles respiratoires
à respirer quand même.
Visuellement on est clairement sur un appareil
sorti tout droit d'un vieux film de science-fiction
sauf que là, c'est pour de vrai :
le patient s'allonge a l’intérieur avec seulement la tête qui dépasse
le tout fermé hermétiquement.
La pression baisse à l'intérieur du caisson
elle passe sous celle qui règne dans les poumons
et ça force l'air à y entrer
Ensuite la pression remonte à l'intérieur du caisson,
ce qui chasse l'air hors des poumons, et ainsi de suite.
La machine a été mise au point aux Etats-Unis,
elle a été utilisée pour la première fois en 1928 à Boston
et elle a littéralement arrachée une petite fille de 8 ans des griffes d'une mort imminente.
Elle a ensuite principalement été utilisée dans le cas
de paralysie des muscles causée par la poliomyélite :
la fameuse polio.
Même si elle n'a pas complètement été éradiquée,
c'est une maladie qui a pratiquement disparue
et comme dans le même temps, les machines
d'assistance respiratoire se sont modernisées, et miniaturisées,
le poumon d'acier n'est pratiquement plus utilisé.
Martha Mason qui est décédée en 2009
y a quand même passée 60 ans de sa vie ;
elle en a même écrit un livre.
Ok, cette fois c'est bien ce que vous pensez :
c'est une pièce de rechange pour les malades du coeur.
Si on prend ca au sens large, y'a différents modèles
qui remplacent différentes fonctions du cœur.
Ca va du pacemaker, qui envoie des impulsions électriques
pour stimuler les muscles cardiaques
au cœur artificiel dit total.
Même si en réalité, il ne remplace pas le cœur entier.
Il y a des modèles externes, mais aussi le cœur artificiel implantable.
C'est un dispositif qui remplace les ventricules,
qui sont deux des cavités du cœur, et qui est greffé
juste sous les oreillettes : les deux autres cavités cardiaques.
Il a pour but de pomper le sang à la place des ventricules
quand ils n'y arrivent plus tout seuls, et il est équipé
de batteries externes qui ont une autonomie d'un peu moins d'une journée.
Et il faut remplacer l'ensemble du dispositif au bout de 5 ans.
Alors, c'est court, mais c'est mieux qu'un Iphone
Le cœur artificiel total est encore en cours d'évaluation
mais c'est pas gagné.
On peut aussi citer les appareils qui
permettent aux sang de circuler
et d'irriguer les organes pendant une
opération sur le cœur lui-même
On appelle ça des machines de circulation extra corporelle.
Le principe est simple : on aspire le sang avant le coeur, on le fait passer dans une machine
où il est oxygéné et on le réinjecte après le coeur
Comme ça le chirurgien peut bosser sans que ça bouge.
Et oui, il n'y a pas que le coeur et les poumons qui ont leurs doublures en métal
Les reins aussi peuvent connaître
des défaillances.
En cas d'insuffisance rénale, qu'elle soit aiguë, c'est à dire que normalement ça va passer
ou chronique, c'est-à-dire qu'à priori, ça va durer
il faut remplacer une des fonctions
vitales du reins
qui est de filtrer le sang, le nettoyer.
Pour ça on utilise un appareil de dialyse qui est à la fois
incroyable et qui fonctionne de la
façon la plus basique du monde
On aspire le sang du patient, on le fait passer dans un filtre
et on le réinjecte, tout propre
Ca prend généralement quatre à cinq heures et il faut souvent répéter l'opération trois fois par semaine.
D'autres machines
permettent aussi de nettoyer le sang à
l'extérieur du corps, comme l'hémofiltration, qui ressemble un peu à
la dialyse, mais aussi la plasmaphérèse
qui permet notamment de traiter des
maladies neurologiques ou hématologiques.
Bon alors, dans un autre registre
Les garçons, est-ce que vous avez déjà
donné votre sperme ?
Excusez-moi, vous auriez du...
Oui, j'en ai
Ah, merci ! C'est pour offrir
Oui oui...
Non, en réalité, c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça se passe
Donner son sperme, c'est la façon de se masturber la moins glamour du monde
On est accueilli de façon très
administrative par une personne qui donne
généralement très peu envie d'éjaculer
Ensuite , on est orienté vers une pièce généralement assez glauque, avec :
un lavabo, et deux-trois revues pornos... douteuses
[Accent allemand] Merci de bien vouloir jouir, schnell !
Mais ça...
... C'était avant
Avant que les chinois n'inventent ce joyau de technologie médicale
Le sperm extractor
L'extracteur de sperme, littéralement
C'est une machine qui fait le boulot à
votre place et qui vous laisse les mains
et l'esprit libre
Comme quoi le génie parfois, c'est juste
adapter une bonne idée
qui a déjà fait ses preuves par ailleurs.
Salut tout le monde, c'est ProctoGaming aujourd'hui
on se retrouve pour une vidéo un peu spéciale
Allez retournez vous, penchez-vous et toussez fort
Pour éviter à votre anus de servir de cobaye à un médecin inexpérimenté
Benjamin Lock a mis au point un robot patient
qui permet de s'exercer au toucher rectal.
Il s'appelle Patrick et il donne
ses impressions en direct ce qui permet à
l'apprenti spéléo de peaufiner sa
technique en tenant compte de ses réactions
Comme ça je jour où il se retrouve en situation réelle, il a
les bons gestes et les bons mots
Benjamin Lock...
Nos anus vous disent merci.
Merci Benjamin Lock !
Bon, donc on a vu qu'il y a des machines
pour remplacer nos organes ou les stimuler
et qu'il y a même des robots patients pour entraîner les médecins
Mais tiens les médecins justement
Et si demain aussi, ils étaient remplacés par des machines ?
Il existe déjà des machines qui
permettent d'opérer à distance
En 2001, une équipe située à New-York
a opérer une patiente qui se trouvait à Strasbourg
grâce à des bras mécaniques reproduisant les gestes du chirurgien
Eh ben il existe aussi des robots médecins
Non, en réalité c'est pas vraiment un robot médecin, c'est juste, un médecin dans un robot
Ca lui permet des consultations
sans être physiquement présent grâce à un système de vidéo-conférence
et de dispositif de télé-santé connecté
Et  c'est déjà utilisé dans les
hôpitaux aux Etats-Unis
Mais bon soyons clairs, de
manière générale et encore plus quand ça concerne la santé
rien ne remplace l'humain
Parce que notre santé, c'est pas juste le bon fonctionnement d'un amas d'organes
qui sont juste là, comme ça, côte à côte à
côte.
Et surtout parce que la dimension psychologique est omniprésente
Et que ça, aucun algorithme et aucune machine n'est capable de le gérer efficacement
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
D'ici là, mettez-vous bien et surtout, portez-vous bien